crece la desesperanza en petrópolis
brasil más de 500 bomberos y rescatistas
continúan las tareas de búsqueda y
rescate de desaparecidos entre montañas
de lodo y escombros consecuencia de las
lluvias torrenciales del pasado martes y
afirman que hay pocas esperanzas de
hallar supervivientes por la dificultad
de acceder a algunas zonas debido a la
fuerte inestabilidad del terreno amigos
46 como aquí en los 46 años que llevo
viviendo aquí estoy seguro de que en
cuanto vuelva el sol y el tiempo se
mantenga así los políticos dejarán de
preocuparse por nosotros así que la
gente limpiará por su cuenta volverá a
construir y al cabo de un tiempo volverá
a ocurrir lo mismo
la pintoresca ciudad imperial fue
devastada por las peores lluvias en casi
un siglo casas cultivos comercios todo
quedó arrasado como esta librería
anegada por el agua
estamos muy tristes por perder estos
libros ni siquiera podemos donar los
porque están arruinados es un gran dolor
encuentro
casi 1000 personas fueron evacuadas de
sus hogares en los últimos días y están
resguardadas en improvisados albergues y
en iglesias donde decenas de voluntarios
se organizan y reparten las donaciones
que han llegado de todas partes del país
todos estamos aquí como voluntarios
ayudando en este momento tan triste pero
es gratificante para nosotros ayudar a
los demás volviendo al curso el
mandatario brasileño jair bolsonaro
prometió ayuda federal tras sobrevolar
la región comparando el desastre con una
zona de guerra